what's happening reject nation greg and
john here today as per use we are late
to covering something because i was gone
this morning the rock sources dropped
their marvel easter eggs and breakdown
for
what if episode four what if doctor
strange lost his heart instead of his
hands and what is the best episode of
what if so far very excited to check
this out as we were watching that
episode i was like i cannot wait for a
new rockstars breakdown of this let's
just get into it
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel
studios what if episode four what if
doctor strange lost his heart instead of
his hands and what if we all lost our
minds with this tragic horror of an
episode unafraid to sentence its hero to
bleak consequences my favorite episode
of the series yet and not just because
it had like 20 mephisto's in it if you
could even call them that but because
this episode was filled with beautiful
imagery and concepts that are
fascinating to break down but you got to
do it frame by frame and i'm going to do
that and point out all the animation
details and easter eggs that you might
have over the week
outline of the watcher but notice how we
see more of his body than usual in fact
he's made more and more appearances with
each new episode of the season as of
getting closer and closer to finally
intervening but by the end of this
episode we do actually see his full
flesh before he reverts to his astral
silhouette i love that about this
episode because the watcher in this one
he's always been just a narrator and
he's just sort of felt that way and i
thought that in this episode they really
made him become a character this time
around it gets you excited at the
thought of like what happens when he
finally gets involved i know he's bound
to at some point get involved yeah
probably next week like a judge who
abides by habeas corpus to render a
guilty verdict in person before
returning to his chambers he says what
if the best of intentions
has very strange consequences it's me in
every relationship
yeah that music was michael g aquino's
doctor strange theme which comes back
throughout this episode
where am i
the ancient one warned us if we save
christine we destroy the world
benedict cumberbatch and rachel mcadams
return to voice steven strange and
christine palmer i love how dr strange
looks so much like better than
cumberbatch but christine i'm like
could be anybody here
i thought richard mcadams did an
excellent job in there and i care more
for christine in this episode than i do
in the movie yeah i mean on the
animation i'm not like oh dang that
looks exactly like richard we got his
benedict cumberbatch is like right on
track come on cut the preamble let's
just get straight to the heart of it hmm
choice words for a doctor who spends
this episode trying to awaken his dead
loved one the heart that he lost now in
the 2016 film strange invited christine
to a speaking engagement i'm talking
tonight at a neurological society there
come with me
another speaking engagement so romantic
you should love coming to those things
with me but here the event seems like a
different one that's a celebration in
strange's honor we need to celebrate
this we are you performed a radical
hemispherectomy it could be another
variance or maybe one of those prior
dates when strange and christine were
still together also we should point out
that a hemispherectomy is where half the
brain is removed or disconnected from
its other half in order to treat
seizures and epilepsy which is quite
similar to the way the ancient one
splits the halves of dr strange's
identity in mind now the wreck is caused
by slightly different conditions like
here strange tries to pass a semi truck
and nearly collides head-on with the car
swerves back into his lane but then gets
rear-ended in the film he passes a car
and collides with it while distracted
but still the wreck itself goes down
exactly the same way frame by frame even
spinning into a pole and then flipping
on its front end into a fence before
teetering down into the water strange
cries over christine while framed in
this broken glass of the back windshield
you think about it this whole series
depicts the multiverse as shards of
broken glass
in this episode after strange has
allowed his universe to melt away he is
trapped inside a condensed prism of
shards crying once more alone so
beautifully symbolic
strange's tragic destiny
it's like the negative space around it
this version of strange has not had his
hands damaged which in the films was his
unhealable wound with that trimble even
persisting all the way through avengers
in-game but you'll notice not in the
trailer for spider-man no way home got a
theory for that keep that in mind
the mastery of his film version and this
guy never having a constant reminder of
his arrogant mistake to ground him in
that guilt instead he feels like the
universe stole something from him well
in all fairness he learned how to be a
sorcerer supreme just as quick in the
what if episode
right yeah
a couple montages that we got there
that was one of the complaints that you
heard all throughout the first doctor
strange movie when that came out i was
like you just learned really quick how
to become this good it's a little more
justified in this universe because his
hands are actually working strange
discovers the eye of akimoto cradle of
the temporal singularity discovered by
cagliostro manipulation and alteration
of timelines yes the temporal
singularity of course referring to the
time stone the word singularity coming
from wong's recap and infinity war of
the stones being the singularities from
the big bang as in the film strange uses
the time stone to unwind and rewind the
bites of an apple and he is caught in
the act by wong and the ancient one with
benedict wong and tilda swinton
returning tinkering with time can weaken
the very fabric of the universe we
protect reality we don't threaten it but
in the film mordo joined wong in
admonishing strange but oh yeah where's
mordo from this episode they didn't even
bring in against the actor to try to
emulate chill tell echo for like they
normally do for actors they can't get
back in there not sure why but without
this scolding conscience it doesn't
leave strange to go further with a
sorcery than he would otherwise you know
a lot of people were thinking that mordo
was gonna be uh nope
as in the film the ancient one dies in
strange bargains with dormammu and
becomes a sorcerer supreme but now he
uses the time stone to return to the
night of christine's death now compared
to the time travel logic of loki in
endgame doctor strange's time stone
magic seems limited to within his
timeline like he doesn't create branch
timelines so much as he relives history
within his timeline by reversing time
and creating time loops definitely seems
more limited in scope compared to the
more technological quantum approaches
those paperwhites scanning the tba and
the avengers who when they alter time
create branch timelines this could be
why the tva showed us the infinity
stones from their point of view as
powerless outside of their home
timelines but since we stay within
doctor strange's timeline here this time
stone is infinitely powerful and strange
creates a new loop point that begins
with christine at the car similar to how
he used a time loop to torture dormammu
but here strange creates this groundhog
day scenario to essentially torture
himself really which is ironic because
dormammu was benedict cumberbatch with
his voice and performed via mocap all of
this plays out like the heartbreaking
montage and groundhog day when bill
murray tries over and over to save a
dying homeless man the sequence that
always makes me tear up because he calls
him pop and dad he goes to the extent of
thinking himself as a doctor demanding
to see the guy's chart the way doctor
strange arrogantly refuses to let his
patient die there's a moment where a
stranger sees christine
watcher's reflection appears beside him
but notice how strange blinks almost
seeming to sense him but no matter what
in this montage death on wheels always
seems to come for regina george
i actually realized that each of these
fateful deaths could have been sent by
strange's future strange supreme form
trying to fix his own mess and force his
past self to move on because notice the
vagrant who randomly shoots in the pizza
shop for no reason
from afar and here in shadow because
that could be the face of that strange
supreme unrecognizable to his past self
i think you're reaching a little bit i
don't think it's him
maybe he said the guy and then if you
slow down the dude actually has a brown
hand oh no and if we're gonna pick apart
people's forearms and trailers we're
gonna pick apart this shadow of a face
i'm gonna say dr strange clearly has
white hands yeah that's right that's
right he's not gotten a tan since he
picked up that gun and if you look in
the profile his beard looks much more
like tony stark's beard probably in this
universe it was tony stark is not a
billionaire playboy he's a bug he's a
bum and he needs to resort to crime to
make his living even when strange stands
her up she still dies in a building fire
numerous casualties including the death
of one dr christine palmer surgeon bile
photo ready to go all the building's
still blazing okay actually that
reporter is christine everhart
he's coming back
she comes back more than more though
portal which compared to the golden
sparkle portals normally used by
sorcerers might indicate a higher form
of magic allowing one to traverse
timelines or directions or realms like
the blue portal captain carter and the
tentacle monster went through in the
blue color christine glows when strange
resurrects are at the end of the episode
now the ancient one would still be alive
at this point in the timeline right
because the night of christine's death
the ancient one was still living but the
fact that she uses this blue portal is
just interesting to note because she is
someone who has seen every part of her
life and every part of her timeline she
seems to have an omniscience to her and
she could be coming to strange through
another realm and she explains her death
is an absolute point in time absolutely
unchangeable unmovable okay so absolute
points a kind of new rule in the mcu's
ever expanding timeline logic that i'm
sure some folks might debate whether or
not it applies to the live-action mcu
titles but for now i don't think too
much again in in-game
past tragedies could be altered or
subverted but doing so would result in
the creation of a branch timeline
thanos's snap though could not be
prevented could be practically undone by
extracting infinity stones from the past
and using them to snap everyone back in
the present though the world still had
to live with the consequences of some
people living five years more than
others the sudden population change from
snaps that seemed like it could have
been an absolute point that they just
kind of had to work around but now we
are learning that some events are
considered absolute points they are
fixed load-bearing watershed moments
that cannot be erased these could be
anchor points that were placed in the
timeline by whatever version of kang in
order to maintain stability to that
universe's sacred timeline so in this
episode when strange eventually forces
christine's survival he violates the
natural limits of his time stone and he
breaks the absolute point of that
timeline careening the timeline into a
chaotic branch beyond the timeline logic
that his time stone could have any
control over it's like the darkest
timeline that the ancient one warned
bruce banner about in endgame in this
new branch reality without our chief
weapon against the forces of darkness
our world would be overrun
millions will suffer which the ancient
one in this episode echoes this path
only leads to darkness and the end of
this reality
the darkness on that hypothetical branch
that she talked about in endgame could
have meant that the [ __ ] would be
trying to self-proof by melting look at
but also evokes the more dark matter
that makes up the borders of this
reality and in the medium of comics and
classic animation
the ink that these characters are
literally drawn in oh that
wow you know um
i'm just gonna give you a round of
applause i thought that was really
beautiful
very enriching detail there as confusing
as the timeline stuff can get from if
you like really think about it from time
to time you're dealing with like the
rules of the logic of the timeline
whatever you go back to oh yeah there's
also that guy he who remains who made
all this happen around like i keep
forgetting that he's like in charge of
this at this point in the story
yeah yeah yeah
releasing all these activities yeah but
then to connect it with exchange of
dialogue and avengers end game this
episode being a foreshadowing event of
what she was warning about not only this
episode but also an end game just adds
further more significance and importance
to this specific episode of marvel's
what if and then also with the uh visual
parallels too like you were drawing
there so beautiful for like the animated
format to go back to the black ink i
don't know how literal all this was
meant to be in the sense of like were
the filmmakers or the creators the
artist thinking about all this when they
were doing it you made a damn strong
compelling
argument as to why yeah that is a i
thought that was beautifully put it
lines up yeah but as we move on from
this remember christine palmer's death
is only an absolute point in this
universe not the universe of the primary
mcu because she's still alive in the
primary mcu we're all still fine so this
would suggest that different universes
are structured with different absolute
points that that kang timeline scribe
considered to be unchangeable so the
ancient one attacks strange to keep him
from going further and notice how her
spell explodes in a white impact blast i
love when the show does this it's really
fun to pause at the right moment like
first she does it when she brings the
edges of her runic fans together and
then when it hits strange it creates
this one black point where he was
standing representing how the ancient
one just split
strange thinks he survived it go into
the
before this library was lost alongside
several other ancient libraries like the
burning of the library of alexandria in
this case cagliostro was an actual real
person in history but in the lore of
marvel comics he was an ancient italian
sorcerer and it was his spells of the
book of kai leostro the spell book in
the 2016 film strange is greeted by
obama voiced by akamati and he later
implies estranged that he is not himself
kagliostro but in fact in the comics
obeng is the possible real-life name of
the actual cagliostro and notice how he
has one blue eye and one reddish brown
what's going on maybe a clue that
strange is here in a split reality split
between a place where his eyes stay
clear blue and another place where his
eyes go darker and at times red the lost
library of cagliostro is beautiful
inside and out the facade of it has
carvings of winged griffons and then is
flanked by larger sphinxes the sphinx is
the mythological being who pose the
riddle which creature has one voice and
yet becomes four-footed and then
two-footed and three-footed the answer
being man who crawls on all fours as a
baby walks on two feet as an adult and
uses a walking stick in old age which
you could see reflecting strange's
journey as a man in a literal sense
taking multi-limbed forms but also lives
throughout centuries as obeng ages into
an old man who cannot stand on his two
feet as he tries to go inside strange
encounters all these protective runes
much like the ones wanda and agatha used
against each other in one division
wizards love runes and oban greets him
sorcerer armani
it's strange not any stranger than any
other name in this world calling back
the name word play that kaiselius had
with them in the 2016 film how long have
you been at carmitage mr
doctor
mr doctor
it's strange
maybe
who am i to judge inside the library
strange finds the book on time
manipulation this is the same book of
cagliostro from the camera taj library
that we saw in doctor strange it has the
same cover but this would be hundreds of
years earlier before it ended up in
camertaj the page he actually opens up
to are the same pages that kaiselius
tore out of the book in the 2016 film
and you could see that same dark
dimension symbol the one that kaiselius
conjures in the church and appeared on
his and the ancient one's foreheads
because the ancient one would draw power
from the dark dimension that's why she
was called a hypocrite learning that he
has to absorb other entities strange
attempts to absorb the freaking same
interdimensional tentacle monster
is it the same exact one i speculated
then that this could be one of the elder
gods aka the many angled ones like
schuma gorath who is speculated to
appear and doctor strange the multiverse
of madness
huge deal that it came back because
other than the watcher himself this is a
first example of continuity on this
series and since the trailer showed that
one image of captain carter meeting the
strange supreme i thought peggy carter
like defeated it right did he like
sliced them up tentacles and then came
back here wouldn't it be like an
alternate version still i guess
theoretically i mean maybe on the peggy
carter timeline we're meeting a
different dark doctor strange in the
remnants because like at least in the
freeze frame they pull it seems like
there might be some kind of tentacular
carcass behind them or something because
to be fair in the marvel comics there's
like multiple tentacles there's a lot of
a lot of tentacles it's likely but i
mean to say it's the same one in terms
of continuity i don't know if i would
call it exactly continuity because like
nick fury and hawkeye were in the first
episode but those are clearly different
versions in the third one yeah it seems
like it would be a variant of the same
being if anything i think we can expect
a later episode this season to confirm
what exactly this monster is and keep in
mind that we may only be seeing this
entity's bottom half and chongqi
promotional footage seems to be showing
some massive tentacled entity in that
movie's final battle we'll know more
after seong chi comes out but there
could be a connection between these two
obang says mystic beast
i don't i don't know why we were talking
about a very weird thing to say because
uh yeah dormammu totally did bargain at
least eventually after being worn down
unless you consider that the deal
strange made with dormammu might have
not been a deal in strange's favor but a
curse that dormammu might have benefited
from strange starts smaller this time
with an evil little gnome and then an
insect whom he sends back but takes its
cloak of levitation meaning that this
might have been some alternate variant
in reality that was a sorcerer and
you'll notice that this cloak has a
darker color and golden lining similar
to the flesh of that insect himself he
then absorbs a cosmic six-eyed bird whom
he strips of its feathers and then a
dragon that i guess you could say looks
a bit like the great protector of
chongqi that dragon turns his skin red
and gives him horns making strange look
a bit like we have to admit mephisto
because this is followed by a freaking
double-headed goat like the skull we saw
an egg of the harkness's satanic dungeon
laughing humanoid being with a skull
head a cape and with antlers and then a
snarling bat demon marvel does not want
us to drop the mephisto theories okay
they don't like i know there's so many
people who are sick of it i'm sick of
hearing about this mephisto he's not
coming but then why does marvel keep
doing devil things and then going
literal devil spiderman no way home
trailer has that with stranger like the
vista is the one who really made the
deal with the comics and then this
happens
marvel doesn't want us to quit they
don't want it they like it they like it
they're aware now this episode never
explicitly calls any of these entities
mephisto of course it didn't but this
demonic imagery alone dispels that
stupid myth that people keep throwing at
me that disney will never put demons in
their properties as if fantasia and
hocus pocus never happen or one division
with its witches and book of the damned
and by absorbing these things strange
gains enough power to be able to
perceive past reality to the form of the
watcher which is the kind of reality
bending abilities normally reserved for
entities like mephisto but the fate of
his universe is not worth risking the
safety of all others
besides
i doubt he'd listen
hello
who's that
so mevisto confirmed well no of course
not not yet technically but this is the
kind of supernatural evil within
strange's consciousness that i mentioned
in my recent video that makes it at
least more likely that doctor strange
and no way home or multiverse of madness
could be influenced by mephisto and
since in that no way home footage
strange's hand is not scarred and does
not tremble i am wondering if that could
be the strange from this reality a
theory i go much more into in our
episode of inside marvel
i mean i guess what i would have to see
because they they bring up the point
about how there's that released image
strange and peggy carter interacting
with each other we need to see what the
progression is of strange before landing
on that theory being there
because unless he was able to absorb all
the memories or something like that of
of our doctor strange because he says
like we saved half the universe together
which this version of strange never had
that event happened you know and it's
easier to believe you could absorb the
memories and whatever i don't think
that's likely i think the mcu mephisto
is going to be
ultimately just a warped doctor strange
now yeah now the next absorbed demons
include this evil elk that makes strange
grow antlers giving him a silhouette of
hella another dragon who makes strange's
face stretch out into a snout a demon
wolf with weirdly a pierced ear and then
a snake that turns strange into a snake
that still has his hair yikes but then
we gotta look at these flashes of body
horror that go by real fast
first they're strange in this thick boy
red hellboy style demon form who sprouts
a second head then strange made of this
yellowy waxy substance then strange in
an insectoid form with antenna and
barbed appendages and then fascinatingly
strange with the facial texture of the
eyes of dorm holy [ __ ] third eye on his
forehead could throughout this process
strange have at some point absorbed
dormammu as well he transforms into a
snarling fang strange with rose glowing
eyes who then turns back into strange's
semi-normal head but his skin cracking
like a paper lantern burning from the
inside meanwhile the time lapse outside
the library shows the lush greenery
wilting away from the cliffside as
hundreds of years have passed so then
strange re-summons that tentacle monster
from the beginning this time slicing off
its limbs and absorbing them into his
flesh ending with this gross neck snap
now it's interesting how the creature's
tentacles still have some life in them
even after they were cut off which could
mean that when those severed parts came
back through the portal with captain
carter in episode one those pieces could
still be dangerous to peggy and the
others of that universe obang reveals
that strange supreme was merely one half
of himself in a split reality and then
we jump back to his other side who has
moved on from christine but strange sees
that this reality is melting into the
inky sludge and the ancient one arrives
to explain what's going on no well wait
a minute
so this must be a psychic impression
sense through a splinter in reality just
think of me as an echo now you may ask
why is the ancient one ghostly now but
in a more living form when she appeared
strange before well before the ancient
one would have been alive at that point
in strange's time loop in early 2016.
and because she's all knowing she just
knew the implications of what strange
was trying to do then but now she would
have been dead after strange had become
the sorcerer supreme and by psychic
impression and echo it appears that she
has left this sorcery-based carbon copy
of her mind which is now flickering
because her magic is fading in this
dying universe and this echo is trying
to explain strange what she had done i
drew upon the power of the dark
dimension to split the timeline
allowing for two of your possible
timelines to occur in one universe yes
so as the ancient one did in the 2016
film she used magic from the dark
dimension that's why she had the symbol
on her head that's why kaiseles would
call her hypocrite but it's interesting
how the ancient one's words remind us
that timelines and universes are not
synonymous and interchangeable they're
really different structural categories
because branch timelines coexist within
one universe similar to how in loki
branch timelines could snake off of the
sacred timeline but that all of those
existed within the same universe and
that the more branches from that sacred
timeline make that bigger universe less
stable so in the end when it splintered
off into thousands and thousands of
different branches that whole universe
was one of infinite more but i'd love
the audio distortion effect on the
ancient one's words but notice how the
distortions feel like a class
multiverse 101. succeeds in reversing an
absolute point in our universe you mean
saving christine he cannot save us
stephen the resulting temporal paradox
will destroy this universe so wong hooks
up strange with a protection spell
guardian vichanti heavy duty protection
spell oh yes the vashanti are actually a
trio of god-like entities oshter hogoth
and agamotto who serve as patrons for
the sorcerer's supreme those who sit
above and the seal of vashanti that
forms the sanctum window is referencing
these vashanti and i like how the grooms
burn into his face these are actually
the same ones that swarmed the alternate
strange in the cagliostro temple which
remember he could handle one at a time
but the swarm of them collectively was a
bit overwhelming for him which explains
why this strange is able to for most of
the battle stay evenly matched as they
talk to each other strange supreme rages
and you can see for a moment shadows of
the other absorbed entities burst out of
him and fire including a claw and a
horned animal's tail takes him back to
the scene
for a brief shot you can see the broken
windshield glass refracting the form of
good strange showing how he is from a
broken reality and in this case might be
a bit less fit for battle and then they
duel strange supreme uses the beastly
demons inside him he turns his hand into
tentacles you bring through a good
strains of shield and then he deploys
sand worms and then the two cloaks of
levitation square off but then good
strange's cloak sacrifices himself
you can even hear a paint little scream
when he tears apart yeah weird had that
that really felt like a pet dying in
that moment didn't it yeah yeah well i
mean it's a living thing i never didn't
realize like how much i cared about that
cloak until that moment we're like oh
man
get your own bug cloak leave him alone
that was a heartbreaking moment man
justice for cloak strange supreme
distracts him with his orb of light and
then creeps up behind him to drag him
into a shadow realm might even be using
strange's ability to see the watcher and
to distracting him that might just be
the watcher but no it's actually his
shadow self and then he uses the inky
dark matter that people are melting into
to form the memory of christine but good
strange realizes it's an illusion and
strange supreme punches him out of it
shattering like a glass pane you can see
those shards falling with them another
example of how reality even a small
pocket reality like this one takes the
form of a delicate crystal just on the
verge of shattering shockingly strange
supreme defeats him and absorbs his
other self and the eye of agamotto turns
red along with those runic rings around
his wrist which would normally of course
glow green but this is no longer
manipulation of time but manipulation of
reality like the red reality stone but
also like wando maximos chaos mountain
red meaning less orderly and more
insidious strange's final form is a
freak includes
wings tentacles horns full of defeat and
multiple eyes just plopped randomly all
over the face now again the name of
fisto never gets spoken this episode but
the demonic nature of strange's
transformation speaks for itself like
notice when he says her name his voice
is accompanied by separate whispers
and as he leans into christine his extra
eyes all twitch independently of each
other
crumble apart these other entities
suddenly vacate his body
this wasn't supposed to happen because
you could argue these mystic entities
might have come out on top hijacking
this sorcerer's supreme to destroy his
own universe so when obang said mystic
entities don't bargain the fact that one
of those could have been dormammu do it
mean that dormammu won that battle
afterwards
all these entities down to that little
gnome might have been victorious here oh
that would be even more of a tragic
twist and i would love it if obeying
says that line to him the main takeaway
from that scene was actually the line
about love that uh obeying has but that
line in particular i kept wondering like
what he really meant by that because it
transitioned into the whole thing of
maybe he's right they don't bargain
because he was trying to negotiate with
the squid one so instead he uh decided
to start taking that but maybe even when
they're inside they won't go along with
whatever his whim is maybe they'll just
you know find a way to enact their own
through him like how could he be
stronger than them yeah absolutely with
so many inside to keep in order and also
because uh the ancient one does bring up
later in the episode that she has to go
down this path you because you're the
one who defeats dormammu if he absorbed
her mamu and or mama is the one who
actually won in the end that would make
all that foreshadowing that much more
impactful and i just love how it works
on like a deeper level in that regard
strange begs the watcher for help i read
about you sensed your presence you're a
god you can undo this i'm not a god and
neither are you if strange had read
about uatu the watcher that would imply
there might have been others in this
universe powerful enough to have
witnessed or sensed the watcher's
presence in the past who else in this
mcu could be aware of watchers perhaps
kang or he remains maybe the ancient one
maybe even wanda maximoff who did
suddenly see someone while reading that
darkhold in the one of edition post
credits scene but strange is left
tragically alone clutching christine as
she melts away in his hands similar to
peter parker dusting in tony stark's
hands i'm sorry
i am so
so sorry
one life one choice one moment can
destroy the entire universe and as the
episode goes to credits we are just left
with this feeling like some kind of grim
cautionary tale but for whom exactly now
sure you could say
i really gotta stop
my sorcerers out there
but the most impactful images of this
episode are the tale of a wizard who
goes too far and none of us are
sorcerers with the ability to reverse
time or rewrite reality well uh yet
working on some stuff on the side i
really think this episode just seems
like a taste of the horrors to come
exactly it's
especially in the live action universe
that's why i think it's definitely worth
considering this episode as having
actual implications on titles like no
way home and multiverse of madness
because it's the first episode this
season that did not use a single
sound-alike actor as if this live-action
cast knows the importance of this story
on their character's journeys and yes it
reintroduces that multiversal monster
that seems like it could tie into
multiverse madness or even chongqi so
there was a time when folks were not
sure if marvel's what if was essential
watching but now i think it is clear
this is essential re-watching you can
support new rock stars by checking out
all of our merch options yeah this is a
game changer
when you get you can write in a custom
shout out that will appear on our what
if after shows get all of that at new
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
brilliant video man love the hell out of
it thank you eric all right guys
subscribe to new rockstars if you
haven't done so already hit that
notification bell for us hit that like
button and catch you guys soon